[Music]
you're used to your body being in so
much pain that when you first got
testicular cancer and you were having
pain in your ball you didn't get
treatment for a long time most athletes
play with pain play through pain make up
excuses in their own mind for pain yeah
so I had all kinds of excuses I mean
[ __ ] with the symptom aside from as you
said the pain in the pole and I really
talked about like that but the size of
it yeah it blew up buddy
blew up what made you finally go to a
doctor had it just gotten so big that
you said okay now I got to go now I had
all kinds vision I it was coughing up
blood headaches but I had excuses for
the hose too so finally the coughing up
of the blood I was like okay this how
their call from me so you go to the
doctor they tell you how to stick you
love cancer and then they remove your
bowl
the next morning right 7:00 a.m. let me
just talk to Robin about this because I
want to show how does that I don't want
to look at you and talk about my ball
you look dirty
get me in the eye and tell me about your
sack yeah so when that thing comes out
right it doesn't come out the way you
think it comes out from the top so that
cut is up up here by my formal trot
belly button down over the top of like
your your pubic bone there that's the
way they going right so they don't come
from the sack and we were getting really
I've never talked about this Leah they
say to you hey we can put a prosthesis
in that will will Matthew cosmetic
things I think that but who cares yeah I
mean like you need that for
I don't know I hope no one's looking at
my balls in disgust now